hello everyone and welcome to round
three or rather game three of the round
one of the ftx crypto cup we have
another game between these two fine
gentlemen it is uh pragnanda vs alireza
firuja and even though we've already
shown two games between them
we are going to show the third one as
well because they just keep playing
incredible chess and this game you will
simply not believe and then we are maybe
going to cover some other games but
we'll see uh so uh pragnanda has the
white pieces and uh he opens with e4 uh
sorry about that and uh for this game
alireza decides to go d6 uh he goes for
the uh for the piers defense we have d
for knight to f6 uh sorry knight to f6
knight to c3 and now uh striking in the
center with e5 we have knight to f3 and
not knight b to d7 going for the
well-known black lion variation which is
uh very very popular today everyone
plays it everyone knows it
and of course you have to be very very
prepared for it so bishop to c4 uh
bishop to e7 and both players castle so
castles castles rook to e1 and pawn to
c6 uh nothing new being played here pawn
to a for h6 h3 and rook to e8
uh we have pawn to a5 now grabbing even
more space on the queen side and this is
pretty much the most popular setup
against the black line you want to get
your pawn all the way to 85 you want to
have the center
and at some point um well if possible
you want to be able to play d5 and
really put pressure on black's position
but uh once black allows it of course
bishop to f8 and now bishop to e3 we
have e capture sunday for bishop capture
sunday for and queen to c7 you know
there is a game where knight to d2 was
played also queen to b1 is a known move
but here we have bishop to a2 by uh
prague and it is now as of move 13 that
we have a completely new game all it is
it goes knight to e5 centralizes his
knight offers a trade here and uh
probably goes knight to h4 he doesn't
want to allow of course uh this trade
and he doesn't want to trade on e5 so
knight h4 uh now preparing knight to f5
and uh of course salireza cannot allow
this with this powerful bishop on a2 so
he trades off the bishops bishop to e6
we have bishop captures rook captures
and now knight to f5 this is now a
monster night and alireza will not allow
it to remain here any longer so g6
chasing the knight away knights to h4
and now we have knight to h5 hoping to
get the knight to f4 so prague of course
prevents this we have g3 and now queen
to d8
we have knight to g2 uh you have to play
this because uh well you can't play uh
something like f4 because this pawn
hangs you can't play g4 because the
knight hangs so it makes sense to play
some like knight g2 king king h2 and
then only when the moment is right
execute f4 so here we have knight back
to d7 king to h2 and now knight h to f6
with pawn to f4 nicely advancing those
pawns and bishop to g7 we have queen to
d3 connecting the rooks and now queen to
c7 uh rook to f1 improving the the
position of the the rooks and now pawn
to a6 not allowing any nasty pawn to a6
by white in the future we have pawn to
f5 yeah prague says it is time to start
the attack uh but uh uh it is just goes
knight to e5 he attacks the queen here
and you have to be very very careful
here for example you play something like
queen to e3 immediately uh you blunder
the queen this comes with check you give
up one night and the other knight will
pick up the queen so yeah you don't want
to do something like that so here bishop
characters on e5 we have rook captures
on e5 and now f characters on g6 we have
f captures and not knight to h4 just
nicely going after that the g6 pawn so
king to h7 all it is a defense and
knight back to f3 attacking the rook uh
re-maneuvering the knight rook to h5
alirez's rook makes it all the way to
the attack against prague's king and now
knight to e2 preparing knight to a
knight to four to hopefully uh win the
rook uh and now all it is just goes for
it knight to g4 with check you could
also consider combining d5 with knight
to g4 simply to have this diagonal open
before starting the attack but it's a
rapid chess you don't have all the time
in the world to think about your moves
so knight g for check king to g2 and now
knight eat knight to the e5 attacking
the queen
uh offering a trade of knights and
prague goes for at knight captures with
rook captures on e5 and now rook to f4
adding a defender here to the pawn and
also maybe an attacker against the black
king so rook 88
and now rook 8 to f1 alireza has rooks
doubled on the d5 on the e file uh
prague has rooks doubled on the f file
and it's definitely a fight with rook
eta uh rook 8 to e7 you do not want to
allow rook to rook to f7 this will
attack the queen also put pressure on
the bishop so rook to a7 and now pawn to
b4 defending the a5 pawn but this allows
alireza uh too much
in the position and of course alireza
makes good use of it he plays d5 uh puts
pressure on the center and also opens up
the queen's diagonal and if you go for
pawn captures of course the knight hangs
so you can't do that so uh prague has to
figure out how to go about this he plays
knight to c3 adds a defender to d for
pawn and now queen to d6 we have rook
one to f3 and now comes queen to e6 just
tripling up on the e file uh also worth
considering is d4 but like i mentioned
it's a rapid game uh so you don't have
all the time in the world for example 92
c5 uh will really [ __ ] white's
position will weaken the a5 pawn and so
on but okay queen to e6 by alireza and
now e captures on d5 we have c captures
and not knight to d1 trying to set up
some sort of a defense here
rook to e to check and now knight to f2
rook to f2 still uh holds the game for
prague
uh to an extent but after knight to f2
alireza is completely winning but it's
not like you can just push something and
win you have to calculate it properly
rook to c7 is one such move that wins
the game but was not played in the game
because now rook captures and c2 is
coming and also if you do nothing just
to rook the c3 is incredibly strong
putting pressure on the queen the bishop
also
covers that uh so white really wouldn't
have any moves here but already goes for
a different idea he plays d for first
now it seems similar you also will have
control over the c3 square but now
prague plays queen to b3 uh we have
queen the c6 of course declining the
trade aligning the queen with the king
here and now pawn to h4 we have pawn to
h5 and now queen to d3 so prague
fighting for his life here uh but it
doesn't seem like there is um
uh you know any chance left here we have
rook seven to e3 attacking the queen uh
offering a trade of rooks but of course
this is impossible as this rook is still
pinned
so queen to d1 and this is the magic
moment where it all happens uh here
you have to play rook captures on c2 if
you don't uh you will not be winning
this game and alireza did not play this
but i will show you why because after
rook captures on c2 what can white play
if you try rook to f7 which is pretty
much your only active move we're going
to play rook c the e2 with the idea of
rook to e1 and
there's just nothing you can do with
king to f1 trying to prevent rook to e1
we still play it and after queen
captures you don't even get to capture
the two rooks because of queen to b5
check that's the the big problem king g2
will capture sunny one and that's it of
course white just resigns here but
instead queen captures on c2 was played
and now uh proc says all right he he
gets a new lease on life he trades
queens queen captures rook captures and
now rook to f7 and now he goes after the
b7 pawn and this is definitely not a
simple thing to
uh to push for the win even with the
past d4 pawn so here king h6 on pinning
and now the bishop can move rook
captures on b7 and now rook e to e2
putting pressure on the knight hoping to
get d3 and maybe bishop to d4
and that will also be winning for
alireza but here we have
uh sorry about that we have rook to d7
uh now
keeping an eye on the d3 square but
still we have pawn to d3 now the problem
is you don't have a way of circumventing
this because let's say rook to b2 uh
here prague had in mind the rook to f7
and all it is i can resign because after
the bishop moves rook to h7 will be
checkmate the g5 square is covered by
the pawn so here d3 at least opening up
the bishop's diagonal the pawn will fall
either way so rook d captures on d3 and
now rook to b2 now it is it goes after
the b4 pawn we have rook back to d7 and
now rook e to d2 now you cannot allow
rook to f7 uh so here we have trade rule
captures rook captures and now comes
king to f1 and pinning uh and now
activating the king also the knight with
bishop to d4 and now uh knight the d3 we
have pawn to g5 offering a trade and now
knight to c5 a beautiful move by prague
and really the only way to fight for the
win here uh prague is up upon but it
doesn't mean all that much in positions
like this uh and uh
here it's very interesting do you
capture the knight or do you trade on h4
before capturing the knight to do leave
the knight just b and allow him to
capture the a6 pawn very unlikely so i
will show you what happened g captures
on h4 was played we have g captures and
now bishop captures on c5 and this is
the absolute most precise you can play b
captures now comes rook c2 of course you
have to put the rook behind the pass
pawn now rook f6 check king to g7 and
now rook to c6 blocking the
or rather defending your your past pawn
uh if you want to play rook captures on
a6 that's also possible but then you
have to trade real captures on c5 and
now it's a fairly quick draw rook a7
check king g6 pawn to a6 but now rook to
a5 putting the rogue behind the pass
pawn king to g2 we're gonna play king to
f5 and now after rook to a8 uh we're
going to play uh king to g4 a7 hoping to
get this check in and promote our pawn
to queen but now king captures an h4 you
don't have the check materials equal
this is uh this is a dead raw so after
knight to c5 uh sorry uh not after
knight to c5 after this uh king the g7
move rook the c7 was played not going
after the a6 pawn and now king to f7 we
have king to e1 king to e7 and king to
d1 of course
prague is trying to get the rook away
from the c file so you can move the rook
and start advancing your pawn uh so rook
to c for keeping the c file and now king
to d2 with rook captures on h4 and now
king the c3 so now again equal material
but the proc has activated his king uh
to quite an extent so rook to a4 going
after the a5 pawn now comes rook
captures on a6 we have pawn to h4 all it
is starts pushing his pass pawn king to
b3 we have rook to a1 now comes king to
b4 and king to d7 if the king ever
reaches the c6 square then it's going to
be impossible for white to win this but
for the moment you are preventing this
rook to h6 putting the rook behind the
pass pawn and rook b1 check we have king
c4 rook to c1 check king to b5 and now
rook to b1 with check king to a6 and
here
there are many moves that uh just draw
the game i will show one such line for
example you can just push the pawn and
this can never be captured otherwise we
just get our king to c6 and if you play
some like c6 check king c7 still there's
nothing you can do if king to a7 just
pawn to h2 now you have to capture
otherwise we're getting a a queen so
rook captures king captures on c6 and
now this is a well-known draw
but in the game uh alireza played pretty
much the own and not pretty much the
only but one of the few moves that
actually lose the game for black he
played rook to a1 and now feel free to
pause the video and win this game for
prague while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on being always a
true master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is king to b7 and all of a
sudden look at this c6 with check c7 c8
queen uh there's no way for black to
stop this if rook to b1 check we're just
going to block rook to b6 how can
alireza fight this this is what all it
is i missed and it is incredible that it
actually happened so rook to b1 check
was played of course he will fight until
the very end rook to b6 rook to c1 and
now pawn to c6 with check uh
forcing the the black king to move king
to d6 and now rook to b2 this is another
fine finesse by uh by pro by playing
king d6 all it is is trying to trick
prague if c7 check seems like it's all
working out you you open up a discovery
king c7 and now you can stop rook
captures on c7 so it was a nice attempt
by already but uh prague spots it he
plays rook to b2 and now we have pawn to
h3 again uh if you go for rook captures
and c6 you just lose that rogue because
of rook d2 check now if you move the
king you lose the rook and if you defend
it then another check and the rook is
lost so after rogue b2 h3 was played
advancing the past pawn a6 prague does
the same h2 and not well you could
capture this right away uh here uh
prague just throws in a nice safety
check rook to d2 with check either
forcing the black king to move away from
the pawn so white can play pawn to c7 or
king to c5 as was played in the game but
now rook captures an h2 eliminating all
counter play whatsoever rook to b1 check
king to c7 and he was in this position
on move 76 that alireza firuja resigned
the game and prague takes the lead in
the match as he has now won two games
already won one and there is one more
game that will be played so we'll see if
uh
uh it will be two two and thai bricks
will be played or will prague uh win
this match which would be an incredibly
incredible start for him defeating
alersa ferrugio you know that that's not
something that happens every day uh so
here you resign because let's say rook
a1 goes after the pawn you play rook h5
you kick away the black king king to b4
now king b6 and now you advance uh
either of the pawns and just win the
game it's fairly simple so yeah after
king c7 ali is a resigned and another
spectacular victory for pragnanda in
round three of the first round of the
ftx crypto cup
uh so yeah once again hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you have learned a
little bit about the black lion uh i
would like to thank nagarjuna ponogoti
rodriguez alex varsilia uh francis heir
and ricky amini for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the ftx
crypto cup until it finishes so thank
you all i will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day